Speaking of football,
we're in the middle
of NFL season
and this Sunday night's game has
the Denver Broncos facing off
against the Kansas City Chiefs!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Now, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards,
like Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
during the season.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for "Tonight Show
Superlatives." Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Tonight Show ♪
♪ Superlatives ♪
-Our first player is
from the Broncos. It's...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ High-pitched ]
Do you accept this rose?
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Chiefs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Broncos is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
"She loves you, bro!
She just needs to hear it
from you."
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Broncos is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
"Is Papa Roach still playing?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Papa Roach.
-Alright.
Next from the Chiefs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Chiefs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Chiefs is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Let me check the back.
I'll check the back on that.
Is that the one you want?
Which one?"
[ Mouthing words ]
-♪ Oh yeah ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh yeah ♪
Finally, from the Chiefs is...
He was voted...
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are your "Superlatives"!